thank you very much i know it's a bit
late but i'm just hope that you all had
a lovely festive season and happy new
year to you all thank you very much
a few notices
fire alarm test is planned but should
the fire alarm sound please leave the
room at your nearest exit and meet uh in
front of the grandstand
at the bottom of the car park i should
say please raise your hand if you wish
to speak and stay seated when speaking
please wait until a boom microphone is
brought to you
you will not be heard on live stream
otherwise
wear masks at all times unless you are
seated
keep points short and i ask members not
to repeat points that have already been
raised
and voting will be by a show of hands
should the meeting be adjourned any
filming must cease unless the express
permission of those being filmed has
been obtained
thank you
right could i have apologies for absence
please
i have counsellors austin foden
hayes haynes jeffries piet
linda pedrec parker khan tomb
and eden
thank you sarah thank you very much we
can move on to item two which is the
minutes could i have a proposal for the
minutes please
counselor nutley
he was going to be late has he not
arrived yet
he has arrived he's in the corner
thank you counselor nutley um write the
minutes could i have a proposal
regarding the minutes please acceptance
of the minutes councilor nutley could
have a secondary please cancer taylor
thank you very much could i go to the
show of hands please all those in favor
that's that's carried thank you very
much anyway against
any abstentions
thank you very much
right i have a few announcements to make
on item three
on behalf of the council i would like to
congratulate two residents from team
bridge
brian smith and dr jill dip rose who
have both been recognized with a british
empire medal in the new year's honors
list
brian smith for services to the
community newton abbott
particularly during covert 19
and dr jill dip rose for services to
to families of children with special
needs in dallas
i would also like to congratulate kareem
hassan the chief executive of exeter
city council who was an order awarded an
mba
congratulations to them
i would also like to bring to members
attention the west bank community health
and care who have been awarded the
queen's award for voluntary services
which was presented by her majesty's
lord lieutenant of devon recently
another notice on thursday the 6th of
january 2022
an appointment room remuneration panel
met to consider a complaint made by
councillor patch against paul woodhead
namely that he had breached the
officer's code of conduct
having considered the information
presented to it which included council's
opinion
that's legal council's opinion the panel
unanimously determined that no breach of
the officer's code of conduct had
occurred
consequently no further action is
required
as requested by the panel
i inform the council
that the estimated cost of dealing with
this complaint in terms of officer time
country mcgregor
what breach is it
procedure breach
yes essentially um what we're what we're
seeing here with the um announcement
decision to announce
um is a breach of protocol i believe
and the breach of the nolan principles
this this is a decision that was
requested by one of the counselors at
the meeting
with a view to naming and shaming a
counsellor over the costs and to silence
counsellors from making legitimate
complaints in their view
and i don't believe that we should
announce the cost
um
you know
it it comes down to
a question of
whether or not we want
to have a free and open democracy in
this council if we don't want to have a
free and open democracy in this council
then we should say so now
and we should then name and shame people
on on things like this the council
concerned made a legitimate complaint in
his view
to announce it as specifically related
to this particular complaint is an
attempt to shame that counsellor and
then silence potentially other
councillors from coming forward and i
don't believe we should announce that
figure
if people want to if people want to and
now they want to establish that
if people want to to check the figure
then they can apply for it through
freedom of information
yeah this is my announcement council
senator mcgregor i don't believe that to
be a point of order i think that to be a
speech so i'm sorry i'm going to carry
on with the announcement as it stands
as requested by the panel i informed the
council that the estimated cost of
dealing with this complaint in terms of
officer time and the necessary external
legal report amounted to the figure of
6130
that's all i want to say it's a
statement and we'll carry on
what breach
i'd like to exercise my right to reply
as was exercised at the last meeting of
this council this is an announcement
i would like to exercise my right to
reply um as was exercised by the leader
of the council at this last public
meeting of this full council i'm sorry
we're going to move on
i'd like to point out i'd like to point
out this is keeping with a pattern of
behavior at this council could argue
money on council advice to prosecute a
vexatious complaint against me while at
the same time spending money on legal
counsel to shield a statutory officer
from investigation
i'm going to ask you a final time could
you cease please this was an
announcement for information only and
that's where it's going to stand thank
you it will stand here
carry on please carry on right
could i now move on please to next item
which is declarations of interest have i
any there any decorations of interest
cannot see any so fine we'll move on
we now move on to
item five which is the the council tax
base for 20 22 23
and could i ask the executive member for
corporate service to move the
recommendation that's councillor keeling
thank you mr chairman
colleagues
first may i thank martin flincroft our
chief financial officer and his team for
producing the council tax base
we are here to consider the proposed
council tax base
2022-23 as recommended by the executive
at its meeting on the 4th of january
2022
as shown in apec appendix a
we have also had a briefing for towns
and parishes on the 16th of december
2021 and subsequently we've had
recommendations from overview and
scrutiny one on the 10th of january 2022
and overview and scrutiny 2 on the 11th
of january 2022
i thank the chairmans and the members of
those committees who provided many
questions which we have replied to
it is important that members look
through the proposals including the
setting
of our tax base for the next year which
is a very important number for the towns
and parishes that we represent and
ensure we establish a realistic number
sorry and ensure we establish a
realistic number for them to in terms of
setting their precepts
can i advise all members that we have
not yet received a significant number of
town and parish precept requests
with the deadline of 31st of january 22
2022
to be straight if they don't put their
requests in we won't collect the precept
so please remind your ward town and
parish councils
mr chairman i propose the council tax
the council resolves to approve the
council tax base of 49
633
for the 2022-23
at appendix a of the agenda report thank
you mr chairman
so thank you thank you very much kendra
connor
thank you very much can we go to the
vote please
all those in favor we accept the council
tax base 49 633
against
abstentions
thank you that is carried that's so
passed that the cancer tax base
6 49 633 thank you very much
right uh we now have a number of public
questions i do mean a number some in the
order of 20. so um
i believe first of all we have two
questions from mallory you've been
getting given
written answers is she here
can i see if she's here or not
yeah right thank you you have had two
replies to your questions have you as
supplementary to your first question
please
yes thank you for your reply um
sorry
um i do want to ask an additional
question but before i do i just want to
ask
about the um vote of no confidence
sorry but
what are you referring to there about
the vote of no confidence
the public vote of no confidence and the
look this this is a question which is
supplementary to your original question
there's no further discussion in any
other area it is a supplementary to your
existing question
yeah and we're the public and you will
ask
we'll ask this question answer this
question thank you
when and how
and by whom
was the risk assessment provided by
central government evaluated and on what
basis
was the subsequent decision to allow and
promote the covered 19 vaccines made
could you answer please
okay it's not really a question for us
cancer connect would you like to comment
cancer conor here please
thank you chairman we'll provide a
response in due course
thank
you your question number two you've had
a written response have you ever
supplementary to question two
um excuse me um
that is the question one could have an
answer please
that was the answer
would you like to repeat it
that's not an answer thank you chairman
i've just said we'll provide a written
response in due course thank you um we
would like an answer now please well
the leader is quite within his rights to
give you a written response at a later
date and he has promised he will do that
and he will do that okay so we in
respect of your question two please
could i have a supplementary if you have
one
this one
we must have a clearly
laid out
precise
response to the questions
this response should show which council
services were not provided from the
start of the pandemic
during what period of time and the cost
saving
of this non-provision
um
yeah
so to show to where these saved funds
were directed and provide clear reasons
for this redirection
thank you
can you reconnect
chairman i would refer the questionnaire
to the
most recent updates to the finances of
the council as published by uh the
executive they are available on the
council's website for all public to view
thank you
thank you very much that's that's your
replies to your questions thank you very
much could i move on now to the next
questionnaire uh i'm not sure whether
she's here or not mia
mia stylestead i believe that is that
she's not
she's not here so she has had two
questions they've both been given
written answers so there's no
supplementary says she's not present
can we move on please to the next
question please
please
that is not an item of no confidence we
are not here today please can you take
the can you take the microphone away
please
we are we're moving on to the next
question which is
please
can you please
could you refrain please
you've had questions supplementary
questions they've been answered maybe
not to your satisfaction but please they
have been answered
no
we are moving on to the next question
could i ask you to be seated please
please
please could you
refrained
i i
this is going to be the final warning
you know what will happen next if you
don't sit down please
thank you
thank you
can we move on to the next questionnaire
please um michelle gibbons
is michelle gibbons here
is michelle gibbons here she has
three questions
she's not here so
we've had uh she's had three questions
written responses so she's not here to
do sub supplementaries
we had two questions from claire pollard
next and she's not present i understand
so she's had written answers
so there's no supplementaries
is there a jenny daley here she has
three questions
journey
daily doesn't look as if she's here
either she had three questions
with the written answers so there's no
supplementaries
and we're going well with this richard
westwell
richard
westwell is he here
uh doesn't look as if he's here so
we are moving on well
so once again he said a written reply
and no supplementary
simon baxter
who was told he was going to be here
simon baxter
we're really doing well
there were three questions from
simon baxter was
going to be present but he's not so
there is no supplementaries there
lin
please could i ask you to desist
is there a lin baxter here
lynn baxter
no we're none of the questioners here
and the final one we've gone through
this pretty quick because there was uh
no supplementary questions
christine scudder the final one
christine scudder
once again
those public questions uh went through
thank you very much that's the end of
the public questions
please i'm sorry i'm not going to ask
you again please sit down
please
sit down that isn't
that it's not something that is relevant
to this count so if you want to take
that further you need to go outside of
this body please
sit
down
please sit down
i'm moving on now
please sit down
i'm sorry
last chance if you do not sit down we
will be adjourning the meeting
right we're going to adjourn the meeting
right welcome back thank you very much i
hope we can continue this in a in a
normal manner please
um in view of the interruption i'm going
to move one of the items on the agenda
so i'd like to bring forward uh item
nine
to this next item which is the den
tinmuth play area refurbishment so if i
come to the item now and i could go to
the executive measure a member for
leisure and green spaces that's
councillor nutley please consonantly
yes thank you chair um
not too close um yeah as you say
obviously the refurbishment of the den
uh purpose of the report is to seek
approval for capital expenditure of 280
k community infrastructure levy and 106
funding to refurbish play provision at
the den timoth
as we all know the den
play park in tinmuth and decoy in newton
abbott are the two outstanding play and
recreation areas we have in the district
they attract thousands of visitors a
year both local and from the wider
communities and from visiting families
that come on holiday which also boasts
the economy of the local areas
for team bridge to be able to put
forward a plan
to redevelop the den play park and not
only that for parents to know knowing
their children will be safe in that
there are three different age group play
areas
one for youth one for juniors and one
for toddlers well i'm sure bring more
families to enjoy the den and the local
area
we are pushing hard to bring this plan
to fruition
with the ambitious
time scale to have it in place for the
coming summer season
the council maintains that its green
flag and blue flag status for tinmath
seafront both highly prized quality
awards this play area improvement will
ensure these awards in the future
the funding for this exciting proposal
is from 106 and community infrastructure
level
contributions demonstrating the benefits
from development in the local area and
the wider district
i therefore ask that the committee
receives
one approved capital expenditure of 280
280 k
to be funded from sale and 106
contributions for refurbishment works as
outlined in this report for the play
area at the den
timbus
to
delegate authority to the head of
operational services in consultation
with the chief finance officer and
executive member for leisure recreation
and culture to accept the the most
economical advantageous tender for the
works
i therefore propose the committee
approved the recommendations
of the capital expenditure of 280 k
for the refurbishment of the den park in
timmoth
and asked for someone to secure the
recommendations thank you chair thank
you very much we've got a number of
seconders there to take your pick
council mcgregor council to call it
cancer keeling thank you very much
councillor nutley all those in favor
[Music]
against
abstentions
that's uh carried i believe unanimously
thank you very much councillor nutley
um
councillor mcgregor
make a comment make it brief thank you
chair um it was just to say this is a
long-awaited um refurbishment of the den
play park it was delayed because of
coved decoy was delayed a year and then
the subsequent further delay every year
for decoy
having worked previously with the
operations
officers
it was it was good to see it coming to
council finally i believe that the
intention is to have it completed by the
end of may around the beginning of june
so that will be in time for the the
summer season
and all i would say is that uh would the
um portfolio holder for open spaces
please keep us informed of any potential
delays that crop up in the meantime
thank you
thank you councilman mcgregor i'm sure
council natalie will do that councillor
phipps
thank you chairman um i've just got i'm
fully in favor of this proposal and i
think it'll be a fantastic thing for
timothy i have got a concern about the
um possibility of delays
uh bringing this to fruition
um if it looks like we are going to be
running late and this work is not going
to be completed on or about the time
that it's stated i think it's july
june or july and we're going to be
running into august
would be better than to hold fire and
get everything organized ready for next
year
so it's either put our foot on the gas
and and get it done quickly as possible
or if it's looking like it's not going
to happen through the summer um it's
worth considering um delaying this until
next year even though i would really
like to see it done in time for the
summer thank you
thank you very much i think the managing
director would like to make a comment
yeah thank you chairman um just to
confirm for members we are aiming to get
it completed for june uh prior to the
summer holidays for the children and for
the the main summer season um of course
we will keep you updated through the
members newsletter of any problems we
don't envision any at the moment but
potentially um given the the building
industry and the issues whether there
are supplied materials we can't foresee
that yet um giving the approval today we
will we will advance the project as
quickly as possible getting a contractor
on board and just understanding that
construction timetable um however we are
still aiming for early june
thank you i have country bullock then
councillor cox country bulletin here
thank you very much this development is
extremely welcome and uh
it's great to see dinmouth being
invested
two questions please one
adjacent to this facility are the
toilets as part of the
um underneath the beach karma cafe the
beach coma cafe approvals
said that those toilets are going to be
removed
and integrated within the
beachcomber cafe there's no date there
for the replacement or restatement of
those toilets
this play area with children it's going
to be essential that a public facility
is adjacent to it
i'd like at some stage to be told the
time scales for replacing those toilets
i appreciate it's not part of this
application but i appreciate that as a
clarification
secondly it's noted that a significant
amount of the funds for this is coming
from sil
how much of that seal is actually
generated through developments in
tinmuth and how much is generated from
either newton average or dawlish or
other areas
of uh of team bridge
again could have that be responded to in
writing please at some stage
thank you
i could i that will be responded in
writing i think cancer con it did you
wanted to come nope that's fine uh so
that will be responded and you will be
kept informed regarding that cancer
beloved okay uh councillor cox this is a
very welcome uh development for tinmouth
it will help our economy but the most
major i think there was a survey done
and the majority of teenage residents
for their leisure go to timber factory
to timber seafront along with the re
decarbonization uh grant that will
enable the broad meadow and the lido to
to function now uh and function for the
future because obviously gas will be
phased out in 2030. uh it's a great um
thing unfortunately councillor bullovan
and i need to declare an interest i'm a
member of tim of town council tim of
town council does the public toilets in
um tin muff and they are going to be put
under in the uh under what used to be
the aquarium and hopefully the timing
will effectively mean that the as the uh
beach coma toilets close the new ones
will open but the uh well the tim of
town council is the appropriate
authority for public lose in tinmath
we spend one in five pounds of every uh
one pound out of every five we collect
on public toilets and we've closed none
thank you
thank you councillor cox cancer patch
thank you chair i'd just like to raise a
point of order i believe it's um the
procedure which point of order which
breach on the procedure for determining
items i believe its customers have a
debate on an item prior to taking a vote
on that item we've had a vote on the
item and now we're having a debate on it
which seems to be the wrong way round to
me um can you make an effort please to
keep us to the correct procedures
that is noted thank you very much
right so we've had a vote that's uh been
accepted so if we can now move on to
next item oh sorry didn't see your hand
council hawking yeah thank you
apologize soon we didn't have a debate i
just got one question on um
two three under wrists
uh it says there that the ashburton road
and i'm assuming it's the ashburton road
play area newton abbott
has come into its life does this mean
that we're spending 280 thousand in
tingworth and this
this will be left behind or will there
be money to upgrade this play facility
as well because this one also is used
very widely thank you
i think it's already been completed but
cancer connect would you like to
in the front here cancer connie
thank thank you chairman council hocking
might like to look at the last executive
where approval of 150 000 fresh burden
road play park was uh
confirmed
and that's got all the details in the
report so any number member might like
to look at that thank you thanks to cons
contact did you know that council
hawking
council mcgregor here in the front
please
um i just wanted to finish off with um a
thank you to the officers that have
produced the um designs and the the plan
and um look forward to seeing the play
park completed by the end of june okay
thank you mr kentucky
council clarence
[Music]
thank you chairman uh could i ask please
what happens to the old equipment
that is being pulled out of the
play park at timmouth
because a lot of it seems pretty good to
me the the thing that isn't working at
timoth
is the uh the water squirter at the
moment isn't it
but someone did make a flipping comment
to me
you can employ somebody over there for
about twenty five thousand pound a year
to squirt a hose pipe at the kids but
anyway we'll come back to my original
question what's happening the old
equipment some of which is very good and
probably some of it is far better
that's been that's being pulled out of
there than what we have at shawn is is
there going to be a
any use of the old equipment and and
could you keep us informed of whether it
might be any use to us our rather
run-down play part which we're trying to
do something about in sean thank you
thank you i think cancer connor has a
response
chairman um if it was fit for purpose we
probably wouldn't be replacing it
but in all of our play parks for example
at star cross recently and the local
parish council asked if they might be
able to have play equipment which might
possibly move due to a development and
certainly the council was happy to
support that where the equipment was fit
for further use so no that officers will
have made note of cancer clearances
common and if any equipment is available
and suitable and fit to be used
elsewhere we'll make sure counselors
know about them
thank you thank you
thank you very much i think that's the
end there
um we can now move on to
uh resume the agenda item seven
oh
right this is a recommendation from
audit scrutiny and the chair of order
scrutiny is councillor and morgan with
her hand up
okay thank you chair i'd like to move
the recommendation from the audit
scrutiny committee
that we accept the invitation to opt
into the national scheme for auditor
appointments from april 2023
this will be for the following five-year
period
and it's an opt-in for uh an external
auditor
there are no additional significant
financial or legal implications the
current costs to us are already 59 000
pounds per annum
um the full report can be found
on the 27th of october audit scrutiny
agenda
the main risk is if we do not opt into
this we'd have to make our own
arrangements and there's a significant
risk that there would be no take-up and
we would have no external auditor
the rest of
the english councils and
authorities local authorities have been
offered this um
invitation and i would like to move the
recommendation please
thank you councillor morgan do i have a
secondary cancer bulletin
are there any comments i think cancer
patches his hand up
thank you chair i'd i'd just like to ask
councillor morgan or anybody else maybe
an officer can answer
about the implications of what we're
voting for the external audit um what
sort of powers do they have for instance
in terms of investigating wrongdoing
within the council um and um are there
any implications as going down this path
and another path in terms of
the the
opportunity to scrutinize this council
council morgan would you like to
our current external auditor is grant
thornton and they focus on
financial
issues and risks and issues that we take
um
i don't think they
focus on other other more procedural
issues i think maybe i don't know if
martin clickcroft can uh answer more
fully than me
he's over there yeah did we have mr
crawford i think perhaps either myself
or or the section 151 officer can
probably help a little bit in terms of
um the role of grant force it's not only
the financial audit also it's all risk
and governance
and the way that we conduct business
i don't think their their remit is to
look at officer behavior you have a set
of um guidelines that are both national
and in terms of our code of conduct
but i don't know if martin can
expand on that
yeah so this this this recommendation is
purely around the financial audit
um and the remit of this
national scheme is just purely to look
at the financial audit of our accounts
um value for money um that they do as
part of that process
and also the housing benefit order
that's carried out every year and that's
that's that's the the sole scope of this
particular recommendation
thank you mr whitecroft thank you
with no further speakers we've had a
proposal from uh the chair councilor
morgan and it's been seconded by
councillor bulovan can we go to the vote
please all in favor
against
abstentions
that is one abstention
thank you very thank you very much
right we'll move on the agenda now and
this is to item
eight which is the recommendation from
uh executive notice a motion and the
leader to present this uh notice of
motion
that's cancelled on it here in the front
please of the microphone
[Music]
thank you chairman i know the uh
arguments uh for uh continuing or
enabling virtual meetings have been well
rehearsed both in this chamber
previously uh and uh outside uh so i'm
going to be brief the executives
supported the
notice of motion from the last council
meeting and in principle council is
seeking the power if it wishes to use it
to hold virtual meetings both in times
of pandemic such as we've have had and
have but also because what the virtual
meetings experience showed us is that it
actually facilitates
a wide range of members being able to be
counsellors people who might have
full-time work or other commitments
enabling to join meetings and
participate fully virtually from where
they are whether they have to travel in
and in a rural district like team bridge
that can be a real help where people
don't have to travel in from the far
extremes
if you take that up to the county
council level people who might well
represent areas say in ifakum or
barnstable uh you know traveling into
exeter for a council meeting virtual
meetings are the way ahead we're all
looking at ways in which we can uh
minimize travel
and so i think the recommendation from
executive
supporting a modern way of working
encouraging a wide variety of people to
be able to stand and be counsellors to
attend meetings participate fully
chairman as well as to give the council
power to hold virtual meetings if there
were an incident such as a pandemic
and and to keep people safe so chairman
i invite council support uh for the
notice of motion and the recommendations
set out in the agenda today thank you
thank you can i have a secondary cancer
mcgregor no okay
seconded by cancer dewhurst thank you um
councilmember you wanted to speak
thank you chair um whilst i appreciate
the the move to virtual meetings is very
convenient and it helps deal with
situations like this my concern would be
that there would need to be
and i would like this inserted as in
an addition to the the motion that there
would need to be a full set
of regulations and constitutional
matters connected with virtual meetings
that we don't have currently
my concern particularly lies around
silencing people who are on the meeting
who have points to make
um in a virtual meeting environment
particularly on zoom where the host can
can silence
and also members of the public getting
access to uh council meetings um which
would also be a concern so if we're
going to move to virtual meetings then i
would think there's a fairly large
amount of work involved in preparing a
constitutional basis for it within the
council assuming we back this proposal
okay thank you councilman i see
someone's hand up i can't quite see who
it is
that's councillor hook
thank you chairman um
i hope that uh
we're pushing on an open door here
because it's
incredibly sensible to to take the
measures that the leader has proposed
and i for one give it a 100
support and everything he said makes
good sense
um
i would uh
add if um
if he or others would consider
appropriate that that we encourage the
leader and this may be an amendment or
maybe just something to add to what is
already there that the leader also
encourages via the lga or by any other
acceptable means all local authorities
to take similar actions to the one that
we are that he and we are now proposing
let's let's embrace
modern technology let's do so
enthusiastically let's look at uh all
the possible gains that there are and i
i
neither hear nor i won't want to outline
those again but
saving time energy climate change
benefits lots of good reasons for doing
exactly what is proposed
but it would be encouraging to think
that team bridge could lead the way in a
national campaign to get this government
to see sense and agree to what is
proposed so i'd like to suggest that um
that uh we we add that little rider or
maybe an amendment to what's proposed
that
via the lga or as i say any other
appropriate means we encourage all local
authorities to take similar action thank
you
i've got a number of people who want to
speak cancer bulletin was the next one
in the front here
thank you whilst i appreciate the
sentiments behind this proposal
my concerns emanate from the fact that
uh
what we're looking at is what's
convenient for councillors and not
necessarily for the convenience of
people who are electing councillors
we have to be very careful that we're
not opening the door
to
abuse of the system and what i
appreciate the benefits that can come
through through proper regulation
we have to be careful about undue
influence we have to be careful about
people behind the
screen exerting that influence we have
to be careful that
um public aren't excluded from
discussions
having face-to-face meetings where
decisions are going to be taken
is
an a safeguarding system that protects
the integrity of the decisions we make
so i'd endorse
the concept of the idea subject to it
being having have had adequate controls
to be able to make sure that the process
cannot be abused thank you thank you
councilwoman cancer doors at the back
there please
hi thank you i'd like to uh if he was
actually put forward as an amendment uh
second councillor mcgregor's
amendment and uh i suppose that echoes
council bulletins concerns that th
this is used correctly and implemented
correctly and isn't uh
abused in any way
and
i think the point taking on from
councillor hook as well is that
of course there are huge climate change
uh issues in this in in terms of the
impact that these meetings have i know
we're saving money today by having zero
heating on which is uh fairly laughable
but uh the looking at the car park
outside uh there's an awful lot of cars
driven here a lot a lot of people who
haven't really said much so i think
there are there are merits i doubt very
much that we're the only council in the
country thinking about this
uh but uh hopefully a change will be
made and it can be regulated so i'd like
to second the amendment if indeed it was
before there's an amendment thank you
it was an amendment i believe council of
gregory
yes okay i think cancer patch
thank you yeah i i think it's um in
terms of the amendment i think it's a
good idea that this be thought through
um but just for um clarification i
believe my understanding of this is this
is not a decision that we're able to
make to move towards these meetings
hybrid or remote meetings i think this
is a request to
government um
but
i do have concerns echoing
council obvious points
about what might go on behind the scenes
at meetings and i think we've seen
within one of the meetings that we've
had on zoom one member managing another
member in terms of their participation
in a meeting and this is a point of
record it's on the video so i think
there's lots to think through here and i
think i would be very worried about
a move to a situation where the public
cannot be present when decisions are
being made about them
and um so i i don't think we are quite
pushing against an open door in terms of
um the case presented by councillor hook
um
and i'd also like to also also reflect
on council doors point a lot of people
have driven here and will sit here and
say nothing
and as happens at many full council
meetings
so i think maybe if if those members who
aren't going to say anything
they might want to sit at home on a
computer screen but ensure that those
people who want to participate in a
debate and and allow the public to
attend then then we do have actual
physical attendance
okay right next i think councillor
malone you had your hand up
hi thank you um i think that in this
sort of thing then of course we should
have dispensation for those that are
frail those that are perhaps older in
years and those who are disabled of
course we should have dispensations for
these people but in in in terms of a
general move towards
technology i i i call me a cynic but i
don't think it has very much to do with
technology uh not in terms of what i've
seen in this council over the last year
or so i think what this represents most
of all is a flight from transparency and
a flight from having to deal with the
troublesome public who are
just such a bother aren't they but sadly
are part of a democracy and uh and
something that we should be facing
rather than pushing everything even more
into into into small rooms with small
cliques of people uh i wouldn't this
isn't this is an open door over an abyss
as far as i'm concerned
okay
cancer dewhurst
thank you chair um so i i'd like to
support this
uh motion um i think it's really
important um something that hasn't been
mentioned of course so far
is the issue of the fact that we are in
the middle of a raging pandemic
and
we are in the middle of a raging
pandemic that is my view and that is the
view of the government
and uh the safety of everybody concerned
would be greatly increased by holding
online meetings
as far as
those who benefit
from holding meetings online it's not
just counsellors
there have been
numerous questions this morning
some of which
were not actually the the people who
made those questions weren't here
if they
if they were able to come in
online they probably would have been
and certainly during the period when
we were holding meetings
in this council and at devon county
council participation was much much
greater by both councillors
and the public
and frankly i don't believe that
democracy is served by representatives
of the people being shouted down by
small cliques
at public meetings thank you
mr wrigley
um thank you chair i mean
i have exactly the same view as
counselor dewhurst
we there was a meeting of dordish town
council yesterday evening and we have a
small number of people turn up to town
councils
we had an increasing number of people
who were watching it when it was on zoom
and broadcast live in fact we had
somebody last night say they weren't
going to turn up anymore because it was
cold because we had the ventilation
they couldn't hear because people were
wearing masks and they didn't like it
and they wished it had gone back onto
zoom i think putting the
meetings online gives greater
transparency greater inclusion from the
public and makes it much more open
we should do it
thank you
councillor swain
thank you um i'd like to speak to the
amendment um i
do agree in principle with the idea of
the amendment that uh if we were to have
council meetings in the long term online
we would need obviously to have rules of
debate that make that workable
however this original motion is not
we're not deciding here today to start
having virtual meetings again we're
deciding that the council would like to
and to campaign for that to happen
and as such i don't think the amendment
is needed i think it would cloud the
issue the central issue which is that we
have to persuade central government to
make laws which make this possible um so
i would vote against the amendment i'm
very much in favor of the
motion um i think virtual meetings does
make it easier for people to
join in council
work and to become councillors and i
think it opens up democracy it is not a
flight from democracy in my view thank
you
thank you cancer swain and council
mcgregor if you would like to restate i
know you want to speak again but if you
would like to restate what your
amendment was so we can actually clarify
the situation thank you
it was just really actually to to
clarify the point actually um
my amendment is around that
we add into our um
request to the ministry of housing local
government and communities that um
we will in indeed put in place a
uh constitutional process and
regulations for holding virtual meetings
and hybrid meetings
so that it can't be abused um
my concern obviously and responding to
councillor swain's point is that
whilst you know we are putting a motion
forward should the ministry come back
and say yes let's go we would instantly
find that we're holding virtual meetings
without the framework in place to do it
properly and i think
getting the agreement to put in that
place before we get to that is an
important step for the council to show
that we are transparent and that we are
handling things in a proper professional
manner
thank you
thank you council mcgregor cancer adores
you second and that are you happy with
that explanation yep that's fine so we
don't think uh kentucky would you like
to
do a reply um thank you chairman i'm
really grateful to all of the colleagues
for their uh comments and i appreciate
the point that council mcgregor and his
supporters have made about the possible
abuse let me just talk to that if i may
um this is about if look at the high
level principle about councils being
allowed to have virtual meetings
as i understand it one of the issues
that governments say they can't do that
at the moment is because it would need
primary change to primary legislation
needs new legislation
so it's not that council are going to
write this week
and then next week get a phone call from
whitehall to say yes carry on it needs
primary legislation
the legislation which affects us at the
moment is in 1972 local government act
but there are a range of other
legislations so for example licensing
committees could meet virtually some
councils are doing that because it's a
different legislation so
i describe it as tired legislation
there's a bit of a mix which came about
for the right reasons at different times
but looking at it now
some counselors have clearly found
different ways to go about organizing
meetings so for me this isn't simply
about the pandemic and whether you think
there's a pandemic or not it's simply
about a modern way of working i think
the point that council mcgregor and
colleagues make about the potential of
abuse is one which is well made and well
understood
i agree though with councillor swain it
should not be part of this motion
because if we're going to have primary
legislation one would expect all
councils to be consulted about how that
might work uh the local government
association to be consulted and for that
to go through a proper process of
consideration not an overnight change in
law chairman so
what i'm asking council to do is support
the recommendations set out at one two
and three if we can persuade the
government to give time uh for
change to primary legislation then we
can go through the next stage of well
what does a virtual meeting look like
what's permitted what's not permitted
and to pick up the very points that
council mcgregor and others have made
chairman so it's a a process and a
couple of stages and i invite council to
support
one two and three as set out without
amendment thank you chairman thank you
council connect well as we did uh cancer
patch
thank you chair um i just think what
what's lacking from this debate is um an
informed review of how virtual meetings
have operated at the council and if
councillor mcgregor is happy to accept a
change to his amendment i would like to
suggest that
maybe
we include a review
of how and this could be done by the
ovary and scrutiny committee a review of
how virtual meetings have worked within
this council since they've been
instituted
um and i wonder whether council mcgregor
might accept that within his amendment
mcgregor
yes
councillor dawes is the proposal of the
amendment you would agree with that okay
right we have a proposal in second for
an amendment um and go to the vote on
the amendment please on the amended
proposal all those in favor of
councillor mcgregor's amendment
against
abstentions
that amendment is lost now we go to a
vote on the the um
motor some motion that council connect
put forward all those in favor
against
abstentions
that is carried
thank you very much that's the item
completed
now we we move on to
item 10 which is the counselor's
questions and
first of all we have a
question from councillor swain and
cancer swain you've had a long and
detailed answer to that
can i
we're falling to bits here
sorry cancerous swain after that
interruption would you like
thank you chad comment on the answer
please i do have a supplemental question
uh thank you for the clarification about
the human rights act 1998 which
incorporated the european convention on
human rights into british law uh thank
you also for the clarification that the
rules of debate in this chamber do not
violate those rights
would the portfolio holder agree with me
that these rights including the right to
protest without fear of prosecution or
retribution are important we must look
after them especially since they're no
longer protected by eu membership
would he also join me in condemning
legislation that undermines these rights
such as the nationality and borders bill
which criminalized saving lives at sea
and the police crime sentencing and
courts bill which creates new offences
for protests that is too loud or has an
impact
with the portfolio
to the right
a simple answer to that is yes and yes
okay thank you are you happy with that
response cancer swing
thank you very much right
okay we move on now to the next question
sir councilman mcgregor i think you have
one or two here
councilman mcgregor have you got any
supplementaries to your questions in
order please question i have question
one um i've got the there is i've got
the response but not the answer um when
will
this council get an understanding um a
full detailed understanding of what a
storm event is as detailed by the
environment agency
see a supplementary discussion that's
the supplementary to question one i
believe cancer taylor
yes
thank you chair i would uh i would ask
councilman mcgregor to look at the
answer to the original question
stated within that thank you
okay
question two
have you got a supplementary
again i have a response but not an
answer um
the designated storm events are not the
same as the releases and discharges
as detailed by
southwest water
i would like to know when this council
will get a full
understanding of when storm events are
occurring as detailed by the environment
agency
and as recommended by the regulatory
body of
what
cancer taylor
thank you uh chair um as stated in the
uh in the original answer
uh the
cambridge district council does not have
regulatory authority in relation to
discharges however south west water does
publish this information on an annual
basis
and there is a a link
in the written response
thank you very much cancer three have
you supplementary questions
i do and um quite clearly um the
responses so far uh show a lack of
understanding of this council's
responsibilities in relation to the
environment
um
i think the the question would be when
will this council publish a full
list of its requirements in relation to
pollution of waterways
for
members of the public and councillors to
look at
cancer
thank you chair
we are all uh very concerned about uh
the
the way that uh our
waters are polluted however it is not
the
responsibility of this authority it's up
to the environment agency and of what to
to
take care of these matters
the
chair of of what has recently said
regarding a recent investigation we've
launched an investigation relating to
companies management of their wastewater
treatments works which will examine any
instance of systematic management
failure or the misreporting of data if
we find reason a reason to act off what
we'll use our full range of powers
to hold companies to account for their
failures and to require them to put
things right in very short order thank
you chair
taylor and uh question five i presume
you have a supplementary councilman
again not having uh
an answer but uh having got a response
my question would be is when is the
executive member for planning going to
actually
admit that this council does have
regulatory requirements in respect of
the environment
especially relating to waterways the
river pollution the pollution of rivers
act for instance is something that comes
under this council's roommate as an
environmental health
uh body
cancer taylor
i'll be issuing a written response in
due course
okay thank you cancer taylor okay
counselor mcgregor last question you'll
be pleased to hear um my supplementary
is this i mean the responses i have
received so far have been a clear
attempt to finesse the answers
and um
very much a case of it's not my problem
so when is it going to be our problem
when we lose the economy when we lose
the visitors and we lose
confidence in the public health system
within the the the local district
i often hear
that we're going to boost the economy
but if we're losing visitors and people
who come here for
water sports surfing kayaking etc
because the first thing that they'll get
when they get here it's an e coli
infection or salmonella or some other uh
dreaded lurgy that comes from from fecal
waste being dumped into the into the
estuaries around team team bridge and
and other water courses
when are we going to act and when
will we see results
do you have a response today i do and i
the the answer to this is is in the
written response already the authority
is engaged with southwest water on the
production of their drainage and
wastewater management plans and we'll
continue to do that thank you
thank you cancer taylor thank you
council mcgregor
i believe now that has come to the end
of the meeting for this morning
i'm sorry everyone was a little bit cold
but that is the way it has to be at the
moment um
thank you very much everyone for
attending and safe journey home thank
you very much
thank you